I don't want to be an egg,
but it's,
it's doable.
I come from it and the language high
now.
Um,
but we have had the phenomenon in Europe
of feeding the nature.
Now Nietzsche is well known for the
death of God,
nihilism and so on,
so forth
and net next to each year we had
Dostoyevsky,
uh,
brothers Karamazov the idiot,
a crime or punishment has also for now
those two,
um,
quite different figures,
uh,
had something in common and this and
that is that they realized,
they realized all too well that
MMM,
if we lose the idea or the awareness
that uh,
the most important things in life have
an intrinsic value,
okay,
then you will create,
then you will get nihilism.
If we don't understand what freedom is
and we think that freedom is equal to
everything is permissible.
When everything's become permissible,
you get mass killing.
When things no longer half an intrinsic,
intrinsic value,
then you don't fail you or your child
because it is your child's,
but you fell you had because you think
he will become a movie star or football
player or we'll do a lot of work for me.
Uh,
you can no longer,
uh,
fell you decorate loft in your life
because you think,
well,
you know,
it would be,
you see,
I mean that's,
that's,
I mean it is the judge Gentek stupidity
of,
of a society.
Um,
with this bombardments buy,
buy,
buy mass media,
which,
which is constantly lying to us.
It's constantly lying to us.
They,
they want to get first ID.
That's um,
Mr. Trump for example.
Mr. Trump is the incarnation of Mr
Kitsch.
And because you,
because he truly thinks that money is to
mode most important thing in alive.
And if you become a kitchen,
like figure like he is,
yes,
you can make a lot of money.
But look,
every sound can tell you that raise
nothing in money.
And this is what nihilism is.
That is absolutely nothing.
So this is a,
what I called the kitchen society.
We aim at a presence.
We ignore the best.
We do not understand that the most
important things must have an intrinsic
value.
And,
um,
that was that there's,
something's has to,
has to be a sacred and that,
um,
uh,
on,
on the level of,
of,
of politics.
I mean,
look,
Mr Karl Rove when he was still there,
mission accomplished.
It's perfect example of what,
when,
when politics is no longer the real
debate about the good society,
when politics is reduced to,
you know,
Surfing Bart Interest or surfing a self
interest.
And to do it well,
we have to create a certain image like
mission accomplished.
I mean,
it worked for at least half a year that
the majority of the American people for
mission accomplished.
Now in the meantime,
they know the truth.
It's not there.
So when the Kitsch Society is there,
we are constantly upheld with the fact,
I mean,
again,
education and education should be pretty
useless.
Should focus on the useless,
should try to make us,
you know,
aware of,
uh,
what the masterpieces have to tell us,
how to gain a certain wisdom in life.
And then of course,
yes,
you have to develop your talents and you
should follow your passion.
But for so long we are already living in
a society in which wisdom is replaced
by,
you know,
how in which a history,
according to Mr. Ford,
uh,
his bunk and all you have to do
religious sects who are telling you
there is only one truth and a 40 and you
have to obey and so on.
And so,
I mean,
are we surprised about what's happening
in our society?
Are we surprised about,
eh,
the sensors,
ness,
the killing or we,
and,
and the interesting thing is that,
look,
we are still living in democracy.
It's not China,
it's not Russia,
it's not Darfur or both places.
We are still living in a democracy.
And for God's sake,
I mean,
you are American.
this is the country we'd start with.
We,
the people now we the people means one
very simple thing that is we are
responsible,
we are responsible,
not those bullshit.
So if we stop watching television,
it will be immediately.
If you don't buy the product,
the product will be gone.
If you start by books,
bookshops,
we'll return.
Let's get rid of the lice.
That is,
I mean I,
I that's also,
I mean what I hope you can contribute
with this disease.
We have to get rid of the lies that I,
I'll be very powerful.
Now.
We are not very powerful.
And will it be addressed at chains?
Well,
what would change in our society if
people still can do what they want to do
but they can no longer keep up the
kitchen.
They can no longer keep up the ID.
Yes.
What I do is very important.
Therefore your interest or whatever,
we know you're lighting,
you still can do it,
but you're lying.
That would make a difference.
And so we need a different mindset.
We have to try to get back something,
you know,
of our,
our,
our cultural setting and starting to
realize again,
what was the true questions are
democracy,
freedom,
love,
health,
all the good fix,
all the good things,
all the important things are that by
definition,
filterable at fragile,
nothing can be taken for probably,
again,
this is also European lesson.
Again,
my mother was in one of the camps.
It was impossible for her to throw away
one single piece of breads because she
knew what hunger was.
That generation knows very,
very well still what freedom is and what
happens to society when there is no
longer freedom.
They know what they are talking about.
And they also know it's never a Giffen.
We don't have guarantees not alive,
not for our society.
So we know and we can even see it on
television.
And if you also see,
uh,
by what kind of forces we are
surrounded.
Yes,
that is terrorism.
there are people with a complete
different mindset who believe in a kind
of holy law.
And so almost a fourth who want to
define it,
reduce the world to believe snow.
Unbelievers and everybody in their
mindset is an unbelief.
It should be an eagle lated and killed
and so on and so forth.
And yes,
it is there.
there are,
uh,
people,
with economic power and so crazy by
their economic commercial power that he
really wants to reduce everybody to
consumers.
And if I'm,
you know,
turn our society into a kind of
infantiles society that we all behave
like stupid childs who wants this or
that and,
and,
and can fight a certain satisfaction.
Now for,
for a long moment,
we know the forces high there.
We know that the best thing can Paris
very,
very easily.
So,
um,
being that the case and realizing that
what all those forces in their role for
variety,
so what's a Sarepta and some are more
immediately frightening to our society
and orders are more threatening in,
in a longterm.
But what they have in common is that
they take away the quality of our life,
which could be on the level of the
environment,
which could be on the level of,
of our civil society,
which could be on,
on,
on one folf.
But they take away the quality of our
life,
the ferry first thing to be done
immediately.
You know,
breaking news,
let's do it right now,
is we have to rethink what is,
what's the meaning of the good society.
And,
um,
as I once said to a friends,
and not that long ago,
I finally had the opportunity to go to
Ellis island for the,
for the very first time,
a statue of liberty then to Ellis
island.
I'm a European,
right?
I'm not an American.
I'm fascinated by your history.
I'm fascinated by the people who came.
So I came to Ellis Island,
I saw this documentary with Gene
Hackman.
And you understand,
knowing the history of Europe,
that uh,
for so many people,
America by definition is if it's not the
good society,
it's the better society because the
horror they had to face in Europe.
One guy's in this documentary says an
old man,
he says,
uh,
the strange thing about America is that
the police is here to help you.
They're also not the case in Russia.
That was not the case in Poland.
That was not the case in France.
So I understand the kind of mindset in
which Americans think,
well,
maybe it's not the good society or the
best societies,
but by far the better society,
the time itself,
everybody now has to rethink once the
good society,
what are the quintessential values?
What is it that Europe and America have
in common?
And how to defend those values in such a
way that you are not a threat to the
rest of the world.
But I mean the American dream worked
because everybody could realize,
hey,
there's something in it for me
now,
the best,
uh,
creators,
the situation with it's globalization,
with globalization in a sense of that,
that,
that a lot of people have half the idea
that around identities are destructed
because I don't want to sound like an
anti American but have the only coca
cola and only a Mcdonald's.
And so,
I mean that's the caricature,
but that's how a lot of people
experience it.
Um,
that's not the way that,
and that's also not the as essence of
the American dream.
So the good society,
what our quintessential fellows,
and then from there on,
what is it that we are doing with our
education?
How do we use,
how a media,
I mean,
our media,
I no longer to,
to give information.
I mean,
far from it.
It's,
it's just one big commercial,
a,
a thing as education has become a
commercial,
uh,
thing.
Um,
look at,
uh,
look at the politics.
I mean,
it's,
it's on the both sides,
on both,
on the liberal side and the conservator,
there was an enormous reductionism to
very simplistic concepts,
which has nothing to do with a serious
discussion.
So there's a lot of work to be done,
but,
you know,
we,
we can do it.
And also we should win because we don't
have a choice.